Time passes differently in the tva
don't miss a moment of marvel
studios loki on disney plus
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
brand new loki trailer video tom hiddleston
also recently talked about what's actually going
on in the series revealed a bunch of details about
the story that we didn't know before so i'll
break all that stuff down if you're brand new
to the channel i'll be doing videos for all the
episodes in a couple weeks when it starts so be
sure to subscribe to get those we're doing that
disney plus giveaway for memberships all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave all
your theories about what's really going on on the
series because tom hiddleston recently confirmed
some of my theories about what's actually going
on who the actual main villain of the series
is going to be and what's happening with some
of these other versions of loki from alternate
realities also because we just got that eternals
trailer and they're telling the origin of the mcu
so to speak in a very cosmic sense i'll talk about
the connection between the asgardians like thor
odin loki and the eternals characters because
odin knows about all the stuff that's going on
with the celestial's eternity the larger cosmic
concept so he knows all about the eternals but in
the new loki trailer you see him hopping around
time and space doctor who style if it wasn't clear
they aren't just traveling to alternate universes
of the multiverse they're also traveling
to the past present and future of the mcu
inside these alternate realities but here's what
tom hiddleston just said about the overall twist
of the time variance authority he said if you've
done something to alter history or alter the
course of the future according to the tva you get
pulled into their headquarters and processed as a
time criminal as you see loki get hauled in at
the beginning of all the trailers then he goes
on to say you could have literally done anything
the tva is an organization that orders and polices
the passage of time they have predetermined
what happens in the past present and future
in a straight line and if you do anything that
deviates from that or creates an alternate branch
of reality you get hauled into the tva and charged
with crimes against the timeline and you're a time
prisoner it will come as a surprise to no one
that loki is one of those time criminals tom
hiddleston talking about this variant version
of loki here the main loki on the series
then the director of the series added to that
by saying with loki taking the test right
fans will see exactly what that action means and
what bigger ripple he's made in time doing that
it causes him to be more reflective about his
actions and why he's done what he's done so what
tom hiddleston is clarifying is the time variance
authority predetermines the future of the mcu they
decide what happens in the future as if there's no
chance of true free will like if anyone deviates
from the time keepers predetermined courts that's
when they get hauled into the time prison in their
citadel or they get a raise from existence like
the person does hilariously in the queue line here
and as he also clarifies you don't have to
have committed a serious infraction against
their plan for the future it can literally be
anything as simple as just choosing not to do
something that the time keepers had pre-ordained
that you were supposed to do on a particular day
like you turned left when you should have turned
right and i feel like this just confirms some
of my theories about who the real villains of the
series are supposed to be it's another Wandavision
situation where on Wandavision yes agatha the
harkness was kind of the antagonist for a lot of
the series but really was tyler hayward who's in
charge of sword comes off as more of the mustache
twirling traditional villain like a situation
where the inmates are running the asylum so even
if the time keepers themselves aren't super evil
the time variants authority just like sword will
probably wind up coming off as more of a villain
than most of the alternate versions of loki in
these other universes the other timelines and
while some of them do seem pretty terrible i think
that's all meant to be a big misdirect they kind
of did that on Wandavision too where they want you
to think that scarlet witch might be the villain
at least in the first couple of episodes like oh
no she's the one that's orchestrating all these
people's lives using them like puppets to her own
whims but really by the end of the series you find
out that wasn't exactly the case so for example in
the clip where loki is getting hauled into the
time theater in owen wilson's character mobius
is getting ready to show him the highlight reel of
his life like basically show him a re-watch of all
the marvel movies even though it's written to be a
funny scene he's actually telling the truth that's
the real comedy there is that loki is not wrong
when he's talking about the quote-unquote time
lizards how ridiculous this all is orchestrating
the lives of trillions of people across the
timeline to their own whims so you're part of
the tva's courageous and dedicated workforce
yes you were created by the time keepers
yep to protect the sacred timeline correct
is that funny the idea that your little club
decides the fate of trillions of people across
all of existence at the behest of three
space lizards yes it's funny it's absurd
and here's even more evidence to back that up the
show runner michael waldron recently talked about
some of the main inspirations for how they wrote
the story i've already talked about how he came
from the rick and morty tv shows so i've already
talked about some of the creative energy that
they borrowed from rick and morty but he also
said that one of the major influences for the
way they wrote the episodes and the characters
was blade runner and that it was owned wilson's
character mobius who's supposed to be like their
version of deckard the hard-boiled detective
working inside the system who's very non-plus by
all this sci-fi craziness and situations they get
themselves into like loki's trying to out-fox him
here and he's just completely unimpressed and as
you probably guessed all the different versions of
loki all the variants are supposed to be like the
replicants that they're hunting down and killing
or terminating if you want to make the blade
runner reference a little more on the nose because
the replicants were more like living machines but
who is the actual main villain of the blade runner
movie yes roy batty the leader of the replicants
is kind of the antagonist but at the end of the
movie you wind up completely sympathizing with
him he just wants to live that iconic speech of
his tears in the rain i've seen things you people
wouldn't believe attack ships on fire off the
shoulder of orion i watched sea beams glitter in
the dark near the tanhauser gate all those moments
will be lost in time like tears in rain time to
die it's all about the wondrous things he's seen
learned experienced that are all going to be lost
because he's about to die also fun connection
to Wandavision again they had a blade runner
easter egg during the Wandavision finale for the
tanhauser gate on the marquee for the westview
movie theater and it was meant to be a reference
to hex vision this version of vision getting ready
to die when scarlet witch took down the hex
his own version of tears in the rain so you
have to imagine that all these alternate loki's
the variants they're calling them have their own
tears in the rain kind of moments all of them just
wanting to live and some of them are probably not
all that bad but in blade runner in that
scenario it's kind of like the tyrell corporation
and the police that wind up coming off as more of
the villains because they're using these living
machines like slaves in this futuristic society
when they've achieved consciousness so they kind
of evolved to the point where they become this
whole new race of people but tyrell the police
don't really view them as anything more than
machines just like it sounds like the time keepers
and the time variants authority don't really care
about all these variants and that's just these
loki's they do this all over the timeline for
trillions of people they'll get rid of anything
that does not adhere to their very strict plan
for the future in my other loki videos i've also
made hitchhiker's guide and doctor who references
to them portraying the tva like the worst kind of
bureaucrats you could think of like the time lords
on doctor who are the worst bureaucrats you could
think of or to be more on the nose the citadel
of ricks on rick and morty which are now very
literally being run by evil morty so the main rick
c137 rick thought they were terrible to begin with
now they're more overtly terrible so early theory
they do wind up getting rid of some of these
alternate loki's the genuinely bad ones but since
it seems like they're trying to hype up lady loki
or female loki here whatever you want to call
her she'll end the series in the most lokey way
possible by faking her own death in our variant
loki will wind up sympathizing with a lot of these
alternate versions even he himself is a variant or
to make another blade runner reference he is one
of the replicants himself but it seems like maybe
they do have bigger plans for female loki lady
loki in future seasons like loki season 2 or some
other marvel movie or disney plus series maybe
she'd come back like i don't think they'll wind
up killing off every single one of these alternate
loki's an early theory is though that over the
course of season 1 this loki our our main version
of loki and owen wilson's mobius character will
uncover shadier things going on inside the time
variance authority like things inside the tva will
only get worse before they get better and they'll
use the ending of season one to sort of set up
a larger mystery within the tva that they'll
deal with in a season two plot when that winds up
happening they did confirm that there will be a
season two like the main plot of season one pretty
simple loki breaks the timeline by stealing the
infinity stone the space stone creates a bunch of
branch timelines that they have to close down but
usually what you do with series like this or even
to make another rick and morty reference as you
get more meta with future seasons the season two
plot gets more meta in that it digs more into the
inner workings of the tba and what's really going
on with the time keepers like i don't think we're
going to learn everything about the time keepers
in the mcu during season one and they'll sort of
spin that mystery up as it becomes more of a lead
in for king the conqueror crossover type stories
connections to that character in the future in
the way he's manipulating the timeline because
if the tva themselves wind up being kind of
villainous themselves even if it's only indirectly
then it would be an easy way to portray kang the
conqueror of the mcu as more of an anti-hero type
of character or at least more of a complex villain
like he is a powerful character who doesn't agree
with the timekeeper's plan for the future which
is actually accurate to the comics that is sort
of his relationship with them in the comics
for example in the comics one of the reasons
why he spent so much time manipulating alternate
timelines is because alternate versions of his
son in his love interest ravonna rennslayer being
played by Gugu Mbatha-Raw during the loki series
they wind up dying so he winds up searching the
multiverse for versions of them that are still
alive using time travel to try and bring them back
it's kind of like what the avengers did during
avengers end game they used time travel to try and
bring everyone back but they did so in a way that
didn't completely break the timeline which is why
the time variance authority didn't haul them in
but someone like hang the conker would be number
one on the tva's most wanted list and it's just a
simple way to make king a more sympathetic villain
so you at least understand why he's doing all
these crazy things with time travel when he shows
up during ant-man 3 quantum mania in the same way
that you understand why thanos wanted to assemble
the infinity gauntlet because he saw a problem
with overpopulation but he's a villain because
only a psychopath would willingly kill trillions
of people half the universe with a snap of his
fingers that actually kind of makes the time
keepers seem a little bit like thanos type figures
predetermining the lives of trillions of people
across the timeline orchestrating their lives
as if they have the right to we need a picture
of space lizards or like the philosoraptor doing
the perfectly balanced meme timeline perfectly
balanced is all things should be but just to
explain the connection between the loki series and
the eternals characters the eternals movie he's
not directly connected to those characters himself
but thor odin the other asgardians are long-lived
enough that odin for example would have witnessed
the rise of the eternals and watched them travel
around the universe at the behest of the celestial
host that created them odin for example would
know everything about the celestials their origin
story the greater cosmic entities like eternity he
kind of started to explain that to thor and jane
foster during thor of the dark world when he was
explaining the infinity stones in the origin of
the universe as it applied to the dark elves like
when he was talking about the dark elves in the
mcu existing in the void of nothingness before the
big bang they'll dig into more of that backstory
during the eternals movie when they explain
where the celestials came from they were created
by eternity but the current version of eternity
was born during the big bang and just to clarify
eternity is sort of the living embodiment of
the entire multiverse but everybody post all
your theories in the comments below do you think
that the tva will wind up coming off as kind of
like sword during wandavision themselves kind
of being the antagonist all my loki episodes
are going to start posting in a couple weeks
when it premieres so make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel we're also supposed to
get a spider-man 3 no way home trailer sometime
soon they might wind up dropping it sometime next
week because tom holland's birthday is next week
we'll just wait for tom holland to leak all that
footage totally on purpose everyone click here for
my full video for kit harrington's black knight
character in the eternals trailer in his future
in the mcu and click here for my larger
full eternals trailer video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!